very you really smoking pot it's
supposed to be when you're in your late
teens or early twenties that's what it's
for
stop doing it if you're older than that
it's an enough already enough you know I
get it that you people can't put it down
but put it down
it'll never be as much fun oh I started
smoking pot at 32 okay you [ __ ] loser
enough it's for children it's for teens
and young adults that's when it's the
most fun you don't need to be doing it
for your entire life your mind will melt
trust me you just don't need to do it
it's not the move there's other things
to do and I know this is super
controversial because there's a lot of
people have listened to this show that
love weed just just try try a little
time without it just space it out a
little bit take a hit every now and then
you know you don't you stop there's
something weird about being in your 30s
and it's like everything's about weed
something odd about that grow up you
know drink wine take pills take pills
and drink wine get drunk OD in your bed
die do something adult for once be a
[ __ ] adult do something adult like
get a drinking problem and lose your
kids that's what adults do
they don't [ __ ] smoke pot and talk
about disappointing the new Star Wars
was lose your firm snort your house
destroy your shelf with pharmaceuticals
I don't care I'm not telling you to be a
moralist but enough with being a [ __ ]
you know pothead when you're in your
mid-30s grow the [ __ ] up I smoke to go
to sleep will deal with your demons make
peace with the monster under the bed
defeat him be him I'm just yelling this
there's just a kindergarten class
looking at me they're like this was an
appropriate pageant man this wasn't
really great you know but that I've had
enough with the weed and living in LA
every stores a weed store that's the
only thing left in the
economy is si tick-tock and weed that's
all that's left
it's just people dancing and and and
edibles nobody can live anymore unless
they're shoving an edible down their
throat how did we all sleep before we'd
I need an edible so I can eat and sleep
what some problem it's a serious problem
little our friend the Kida runs our
website little Alex then we're gonna
start making him smoke weed because he's
like very tiny for like medical reasons
right yeah cuz he can like eat he fills
up very quickly and he needs to like
blow himself up because he's like this
tiny little bird-like creature and he
needs to just get bigger so what he
needs to do is smoke weed so he just
eats brownies and stretches his stomach
out or something okay I don't know I
don't know how it works folks I'm just
saying I'm not trying to I don't want
the wrath of the weed people here I'm
just saying it's [ __ ] do something
adult you know and there's nothing adult
but like there's something adult about
developing an addiction to painkillers
there's something classy about a nice
corporate pill slides right down little
feed little Fiji water you slide that
sexy pill down your throat and you just
light up a little sig lady and you have
fun stop the nature weed [ __ ] embrace
the Sackler family embrace go sometimes
I wonder sometimes I wonder like what if
there are impressionable people that
listen to this like I'm I'm joking now
but I'm also serious in a way like I
don't like the weed culture is not for
me it's grotesque
it's truly grotesque people that shall
we their stupid when you when they're
when they're out and they start talking
about their weed company you wanted to
throw yourself in front of a car because
or you want to throw them in front of a
car they're they're uninteresting people
a
hey these are talking about with my
friend Michael took a weed all the time
you know and he tries to make it sound
like he's you know building a
supercomputer it's like you shut the
[ __ ] up yeah people you have weed and
people smoke and I get the fundamentals
of the business I get what it is oh you
put weed in the gummy bear now you put
it in a meatball you put it in a brownie
I know what you're doing about you don't
have to go on like your Warren Buffett a
weed and talk about how fascinating
we're gone a lot of shop you got grow or
grow operation shut up we don't need
your mouth shut up at the weed business
uh 'king interesting a beard you see if
you're working with the cartel the
[ __ ] chop people's heads off but it's
not [ __ ] interesting when you [ __ ]
tell me you're having a probably a
graphic designer
this [ __ ] kid are we hard not working
hard shows up late and it's shut up I
could listen my [ __ ] friends talk
about their stupid corporate jobs I
don't need that a friendship with me
requires you to shut your mouth and let
me speak we sit down we have a lunch I
talk for 45 minutes at the end of the
lunch you I hand you you I will hand you
a script these are the three lines
you're allowed to Sarah I can't believe
you are not more famous it is a tragedy
then you also say everything you do is
so good and it's all moving in the right
direction don't worry about it it's
gonna be great and then I say thanks man
I appreciate it and then we leave the
restaurant and I pack and that's a
friendship with me there's nothing else
there's no you tell me about your the
office politics it does the weed shop
who cares
oh he goes he said to me one day goes
your business is so you only have to
rely on yourself I have to rely on all
these other people you'd stop I have to
rely on all these other people there's
so many people there's so many things
it's so hard everybody's dog you know
all you got to work oh you got to work
you can't just sit around get high and
walk your dog well welcome to welcome to
the races
yeah he gave a bunch of degenerates
office buildings now they're all [ __ ]
legged sword yeah it's easy to sit and
Wendy's and sell dime bags to me and my
dirtbag friends sorry it's a little more
difficult now that to go he's like
everybody's the government's involved
and regulate hee ha that's what it is
you have a business now you're not just
selling ace from your mom's Camry I
don't even know what I'm saying at this
point I just know that I'm I am my
righteous anger as well earned and I'm
right know that I'm right I know that my
targets adjust and I'm right that's all
you just have to follow me folks I'm not
saying you should do oxycontin I'm
saying and you can't even argue me on
this it is more adult to be addicted to
percocet than it is to be high all the
time I just respect a corporate
addiction I respect when someone shows
up and they're scratching because you're
on opiates not fentanyl that's too much
too far but I respect a person who's you
know just addicted to a kind of a a more
exclusive drug that's all don't smoke
weed all the time we don't need it you
don't need it all the time it did dims
you it dulls you it makes you even less
interesting than you are sober you're
even less interesting than you are right
now with the weed you know enough with
the weed all the time now we are
sponsored by a lot of weeds companies
and that now this is awkward because I
do I do want to say that everything I
just said was a bit and a joke
and I don't mean any of it and that I
think weed is great it's natural it's
fun it's sexy and great I want everyone
to do it every minute of every day
every minute of every day I just want to
smell weed I just want to live at
Coachella I want to live in a music
festival where everybody's high all the
time and nobody
exactly who's talking to who what what
um
I'm kidding we don't we don't have any
wheat sponsors but uh I'll just tell you
you know I get it your mind gets melted
and you know I've been addicted to
marijuana alcohol percocet cocaine
vicodin but really led me to Ferguson
I've been addicted to all those things
and you can kick them you can be done
with them and I'm not I'm not saying
that they're all the same but weed is
annoying it's like an annoying addiction
you know it's annoying it annoys me I
would rather you go take pills in your
bathroom and I don't have to deal with
you and you could I can you we can you
can suffer in silence just go to your
desk just take what you need to and go
to your desk I don't want to have to be
inundated with your culture of your drug
you know I used to take psychedelics I
never got into the culture of
psychedelics which is like go to nature
be a better person I never did that I
would take acid and go to the Garden
City hotel and talk about the fact that
the people lived in the next Hanover
Rockville Center hadn't really made it
I'm like they don't have any real
[ __ ] money okay because I embraced
the material even when I was high I knew
that the material world was right but I
the MPA it doesn't matter I take the
empty I go to the [ __ ] I go to the
other realm I'll try to sell the aliens
condos I'll convert them they'll be like
we're all hyper sound I'd be like will
you shut the [ __ ] up do you want a
stunning estate yes or no I don't need
to culture these drugs you can do a sit
and be a materialistic piece of [ __ ] I
did it for years you don't have to
embrace you don't have to become a
better person on psychedelics you can
fight it you could just take shrooms and
touch your friend's dick you don't have
to you don't have to have any great
realizations you can avoid them you
could avoid those you can avoid those
realization
like the plague I get it for years you
don't have to be a better person while
taking psychedelics you can just be the
same shitty person you are except you
see trails I mean that's what it is how
much longer do we have we're at fifty
eight fifty we get we got to wrap this
up because we have some ads and we have
some other things to do and I haven't
eaten since lunch I do need to eat
something I will begin the keto journey
again very soon the keto journey will
begin again I've been off keto because
it is very hard to stay on it
because it's very restrictive but I will
be getting back to it very shortly that
keto cookie guy was gonna sponsor the
shower he [ __ ] he [ __ ] hightail it
out of here
[ __ ] you the cookies suck they did they
got sugar alcohols in if they make you
[ __ ] can't have cookies don't eat good
don't you can't ever replace my cookies
Bryan Callen something when I was on
keto three days he knew it I was like
have you heard of the keto bakery bran
Kalecgos this is not gonna work is it I
was like geez a keto bakery in Santa
Clarita you guys this is not gonna work
but to bring it full circle here's where
I think about Kobe no I'm kidding